Jonathan my father in the man in black
is such a fascinating film and at the
same time it exposes many things that a
lot of people would have trouble talking
about and I commend you for coming forth
on a lot of those topics tell us why did
you make the film I made the film quite
by accident it began as a series of
notes I took in a spiral notebook as a
means to kind of deal with my father's
suicide and do some form of therapy as a
consequence and one day my mother
discovered these notes over coffee and
said some you should write a book and I
said mom I'm not a writer but I had
worked in television for many years and
I thought them the subject might make an
interesting music documentary about
Johnny and my father saw to which my
friends who read the treatment Hollywood
writer friends said no this is a movie
and you should tell it from your point
of view
you